what dude like dude you can't pick three
dude the three every time you get to the
third thing you do it's fine play the
part where you passed out amazing dude
hey julius
hey i wasn't making this video actually
has a question i'm pretty sure you guys
uh how can normal guys get normal dates
and relationships without having like
the fastest cars the biggest houses
the biggest complex legs that were the
biggest [ __ ] you know without turning
into an [ __ ] uh how do we get decent
girls you know that bright out looks you
know uh
died without like mega amounts of money
magic tricks and
changing our own personalities
um
i like the way you guys put stuff
together you guys are a family unit it's
pretty tight oh yeah you have good work
i like chris's ferrari
okay well
it's solid the ferrari okay thanks for
listening guys yeah man i mean
i mean it's our podcast bro you're
listening to us dude he just died in the
middle he's
i like chris ferrari
so
that was the third one that he liked
about us by the way yeah you know big
fan you guys are a family i love the
podcast um i like chris's ferrari anyway
thanks for listening to my podcast
dude fine play the part where he passed
out amazing dude go back and play the
part we passed out please do it you're
so funny
i'm making this video actually
i'm pretty sure you guys
uh how can normal guys get normal dates
and relationships without having like
the fastest cars i mean this guy doesn't
move at all
because cox slid it in there
turn it into an [ __ ] watch when he
dies uh i don't get decent girls you
know that bright out looks you know uh
that's so weird
bright outlooks that's a good thing i
know but
i died
mega amounts of money
magic tricks
all right cool look man magic tricks you
know that was the third one this guy his
his [ __ ] his lists fall apart at number
three you know what i mean like what do
you want to eat um i have a turkey
sandwich uh potato salad
car parts
like
why dude like dude you can't pick three
dude the three every time you got to do
the third thing yes i really love you
guys your family you guys are hilarious
chris's car
how do you get chicks without having
money a great personality
magic tricks
[Music]
this guy can't do three things she
should stop it too
um oh [ __ ]
hello
[Music]